our next example is multiple linear
regression where we have more than one
column added to the design Matrix so
here we'll we'll use the um uh age
variable as well as the L stat to
um uh to predict the median value in
census districts and as above if we just
want the design Matrix directly we'll
use this fit transform method uh which
calls fit and then transform just as a
shorthand but really what's going on in
the hood first fit is called and then
Transformer is called on Boston oh so
here you do it all on the Fly called
Model spec Ms and the fit and transform
and it just creates a matrix X all in
one yes whereas above we did in inal
steps I
yeah okay so as above we create the
design Matrix the stats models object
and then we can summarize the results to
get our table as we saw above and now
there's an effect for Al that an effect
for age and of course these are
interpreted just as above um estimates
of the coefficients standard errors um
Etc okay
um so now
let's do another example so here we had
two columns and easy to make a list of
two columns but we might have an example
in this case there are 13 or so features
in the Boston data set and if we wanted
maybe all but or all of the features um
that be we'd have to write all 12 of the
names that would be kind of a pain would
tedious yes yeah but well so how do you
know of course py python is just a
language we can find all the columns
that aren't median value so um if we
just look at The Columns of Boston and
drop the median value this gives us all
12 of the column names and then we can
just pass that as our argument to model
spec and now we'll get a model that has
all the you know all the features except
of course the response um Fe in the in
the regression model well that's very
convenient yes okay now suppose we
wanted all but age well we would just
similarly drop
age and of course okay we don't need to
inspect that it'll just have one row
less um and it will be the fit as if we
dropped
age